all right Dan Dan where you from
urgently where' you grow up Mich
Michigan
Michigan tell me about your uh childhood
you you grew up with Mom and Dad very
big um yeah very what
abusive abusive AB abusive
very um my mother we should probably
explain you had you had a stroke
recently so yeah I had a stroke
I you I can't talk now walk my hands
nothing I hate it people go like this
because they feel drunk and don't even
drink know people think you're drunk
yeah I'm not it piss me off and I always
want to fight because of it cuz I don't
know you
know uh they just want to
assume and I hate I hate I hate I hate
it you were fine you were fine the rest
of your life yeah F here and the stroke
just happened recently I a stroke
happened u i was watching back from
Walmart
and I was
dead uh I was robed when I dead some so
my water in my my
phone and I was a month coma a month in
a coma no and a five months of my own
hospital and they not like this you know
and my life already suck and was now
really sh so so back to your childhood
yeah um it was abusive you said uh my
mom divorced my father when I was
two and I met my father again when I was
1974 and uh in
2iz and uh that lasted about a month you
know my father was a Dr
addict and uh
b a b you know
um he smoke weed
Dr assd and all
that and uh uh one day he come
home uh from work and beat the [__] out
of me with his fist of fine pan and all
kind of [__] and threw me out door all
because of a phone bill because of a
phone bill phone bill yeah I R
up4 some dollars in Long dist
cost and he beat the hell and through me
door you know um when I met my father he
gave me uh my first of window pain
LT L I said D and D he just a cute
have standing FR me come ha you know and
uh that all that about a month so uh
than you out and I B
around state to state uh I end up back
in
Michigan and uh I'm back to school I
graduated high school I wrestled I took
third in
state um I I got
my and went to K twice for
cooking and my mom REM married my dad
who was very abusive to her and me he
beat her and me and wash the homes and
so
on and
uh finally uh he commed suicide in
1978 and my real father committed
suicide in
1986 and um I
I
um I went to a party one time in
1998 I went to
party uh I end up touching an underage
girl in the best that's it just best and
uh she Dr and drw all and I wouldn't
give her any more alcohol you know and
so she told that I her and I'm went to
quit and the just H Me Out To Die
uh I'm sorry sorry what happened touch
her breast oh you touched her breast she
be she was very about anyway um I did
not have no right tou to her because I
was adult she was a kid and I knew that
but know I was under the influence of Z
SH I didn't care anything
and didn't matter you
know but
I uh I did 12 Years straight in prison
and
uh uh I did six class and all that and
uh my life had been total
hell since because of that 199
um my
upbringing my dad
Sude my
abusiveness my drugs and drinking and
and uh and such crime all that it just
[__] my whole life you know I haven't
had
a h a relationship I've been married 19
years
and it was a good Mar mywife just died
from Val
fever uh
recently and um
no um I haven't
had a relationship with love I haven't
had a place live which is because of my
past and um
I have met nothing since
nothing I've been on the
street I bounce around place to place I
get so security and
disability uh but it's not enough you
know how do you make money then I either
when I'm broke I'll fly shine I'll hold
and ramp pan handle that P yeah um and
that's how I make money uh I can't work
cuz I drop [__] for all the time you
know
um it's very hard now for me to work
before I could work but and I did now
it's very hard cuz my hands are dead I
can't oh
nothing I can't uh can't all the time I
just I'm my mess you know um there's
nothing for me you know nothing do you
have any
friends uh yeah but I don't have a best
friend or anybody that I can actually
call a
friend I know a lot people but I I don't
uh I don't
uh I don't have a a friend right do do
you have children I got a daughter I
never met um I tried one time um I went
to a college you know
ASU
Arizon I went to the beans office got to
his and turn on that because I didn't
hurt you got mean like about know I just
didn't my take chance hurt
about I never met her I the doctor tell
I I have a very low
SPM I can't have kids it 19 years
her what's your biggest fear now you're
62 yeah 62 what's your biggest what's
your biggest fear now um you know
um I don't want to be
alone um I have I am I'm not so Sor
because God is can take your life and I
know that now um I want to die but I
won't kill myself I've tried you know I
just can't die I I hang
myself uh come
outside my feel over
doers I I always live I just can't die
and I had a heart stroke and uh I died
and I was
robed and I was a coma and hot they you
know
you you know
um
um I'm would say my B Fe is uh being
alone are you living on the streets now
yeah I am
no um cold I'm
hungry I'm I'm I'm diry you know uh I
have about CLE problem I like cleaniness
you know and drugs are you using drugs
yeah um I abuse everything I touch you
know um I tried F all I died every time
I did so I don't
do um I like I smoke
it
not of it by for
me
um yeah I don't read read no because I
call all the time you know
um uh
I just
don't I
like
Bo I like the outdoors and most [__]
that looking back at your life do
you do you think you've learned anything
from all your ups and
downs
um I'm the
opposite of my dad they beat the h
b
kids um I don't get mad I do but I don't
express it you know
um uh I've never hit one I've never
demean one never no I just don't believe
that in that you know um
so I would say uh because of my
brain I don't do none of that cuz it's
wrong you know I'm not stupid I know
it's wrong did you feel like the uh that
sexual abuse case that you did prison
time for oh is what derailed your life
yep most
defly yeah but it's I got I don't know I
just
God I
like I like G I
like it just ruined my whole life I
ruined my whole life do do you replay
that event back in your head and wish
you had played it differently um I you
know
what if somebody I want to kill her you
know because uh
she drank J
andit and [__] around I never did
not know
but uh if I could go
back I would if I was a
killer I would go back slau my whole
family you know but I won't because I
know it's wrong you know and but I would
sh with them and I will go back to
Bey
and oh I guess I would teach her I
because I think she known anything from
her
life I'm almost 100% sure that she got
kids and Dad work and Dad D
because of her up her life know um no
she I just uh I it's wrong to touch
underage person do you think she was you
think she knew what she was doing and
she was just she was very fast mostly y
she knew what you was
doing but that didn't matter you
know just doesn't matter in the eyes of
the coach you know the law state young
adult Tre kid no
do and she knew
it
and if she knew what my life would like
but now I don't know if it would bother
her or or what I just
but
uh my life is [__] up you U my mom I
look at her eyes I see D it i s
green Sparkle glare nothing I just see
Den in my mother's eyes my mom's
alive
um she had three boys were all AR
Aries and my little brother Harry just
killed his wife and
himself My
Girl U because his kids kept their kids
away from him because she was a
drunk I
mean only when he dranks and they didn't
want their kids around him so they
wouldn't allow them to go see him to
kill his wife and
himself yeah so just
me he uh shut up and drank drug man I he
could everything you know he uh s read
your brother yeah and he's a
63 I'm
62 and
uh
um he's been married to the same girl
for like 30 something years now and she
can't have kids no but but he uses the
drugs as well he did
and he stopped yeah but KN weed that's
it to my
eyes he's a sh M and and drink and all
but he don't now he sell money on
eBay
cury and he a house in two
every and uh he married to a lady who
had made
OCD how do you think you'll spend the
rest of your life do you think you'll be
on the streets from here on out or do
you think you'll I hope not have life
left but
um I know I
search for a
relationship but all the
other and people who use you and play
you and see you and I
give more than you could
take know I would say every month I get
paid uh I get beat off because I'm
always for drw and pie whatever and
always work and get new you know and
played or whatever
and I knew
lot
very my mother said I spend my money
for U gble to
trusty and
U
and
this is this is the first time
i'
have
um stuff and
Sh the first time what first time i'
expressed myself oh You' expressed
yourself anything about my life you know
um and time all right D thank you so
much for sharing your
story I wish you lots of luck out
here
TR um right now I'm in
down but it's like every time I go to
the children and Child by the bush they
find out my fth my past and my El it
follows you it follows you everywhere
you go it follows everywhere Y and never
go away and it's really everywhere I
can't
away going right down here to the
shelter it get that I'm hungry and I CU
i c and
uh no I'll try to get a poli St and I
won't tell them about my past hopefully
they won't find out all right I'm part
excellent thank you
d
I